[Musique]
pendant que je heurter violemment les
eaux sombres et froides du pacifique
je me suis rendu compte de ma situation
alors à je ne sais absolument pas où je
vais mais l'eau de mer ça pique les yeux
c'est à cet instant précis je ne devrait
plus être sur cette planète mais il se
trouve que j'y suis encore pourquoi
parce que monsieur a tiré sur moi je
suis au courant a tiré sur moi
oui j'ai entendu ce pas la peine d'en
parler pendant des heures j'ai compris
ça va je suis tout mouillé je suis
complètement gelé j'ai un poisson
visqueux sur la quête est clairement je
n'arriverai jamais à rejoindre san
francisco tout seul d'accord aller en
voiture sérieux tu veux vraiment m'aider
je crois que c'est un petit peu de ma
faute si tu te retrouve bloqué ici non
c'est pas un petit peu de ta faute c'est
juste carrément ta faute ok c'est
carrément de ma faute est ce qu'on peut
y aller oui une virée entre potes songe
à le regretter soli nos filles au cinéma
le 12 février